That the person who is expelled
the human being
from their body
gets to pick and choose who they want around.
Oh, my god, yes.
Can we have this conversation?
The entitlement that some people feel
to a child that is not their biological child,
it is, in fact,
their grandchild, is insane.
I had pretty serious boundaries
when it came to the birth of my children.
I still have some pretty serious boundaries
around the care and keeping of my children.
But I'm gonna take this
conversation even a step further.
Grandparents are not entitled to their grandchildren
at really any phase.
You are not owed those children,
but definitely not around the birth.
Birth can be traumatic,
they can be hard to heal from,
they can be psychologically damaged,
and they are extremely vulnerable
and intimate experiences.
You have to feel so safe and supported
in that vulnerable moment
by every single person that is around you.
That may or may not include your in laws,
your siblings,
or your own parent.
And anyone who has a problem with that
is outing themselves on their own sense of entitlement.
The grandparent relationship
will always be an extension
of the relationship you have with your own children,
because no one owes you their baby.